hello everyone i would like to welcome
you on kaiden's webinar on how can you
characterize your crisper gene edits
faster and easier
which will be presented today by dr
dominica marturana
my name is paula and i'm your host for
today's webinar
before we begin the presentation we have
a few housekeeping issues to go over
first could you please find ask question
box in your on 24 panel
and let me know if whether all the audio
is working and that you can hear me
clearly you can just type in hi or hello
all attendees will be listen only mode
and
to avoid any background noises during
the presentation so if you experience
any background issues
and connection issues as such such as
you can't see the sights or you can't
hear the audio
please type that in the chat box
in addition please use this ask question
box to submit your questions and
comments throughout the webinar and our
presenter will answer these at the end
of the presentation we'll have q a
session at the end of the webinar
okay i already see first responses thank
you very much
and before we begin i would like to
quickly go through the disclaimer
hydrogen products shown here are
intended for molecular biology
applications these products are not
intended for the diagnosis prevention or
treatment of the disease
and we are joined today uh by our
speaker dr dominica martirana who is an
r d scientist working on gene regulation
product development at kyogen hilton in
germany
she studied molecular and cellular
cellular biology at the george august
university in gottingen in germany where
she received her phd in 2019.
her phd research focused on the
transcriptional regulation of the
unfolded protein response in both fungi
and higher eukaryotes
along the way she has gathered extensive
experience in gene editing and in
regulation in different international
projects
since johnny kaijen in 2019 dr martirana
has been involved in developing crispr
and functional gene regulation related
products
and now i will hand over to dominica
so good morning everyone and thanks
paula for the kind introduction
uh i would also like to welcome all of
you to this webinar um i'm glad to have
the opportunity to present you how to
easily characterize crispr gene edits
with added speed
but before doing that let's start with
some basic information on crispr
crispr stands for clustered regularly
interspaced palindromic repeats and was
firstly discovered in the late 80s and
later on described as potential
bacterial immune system to fight viral
viral infections
the principle is quite easy so
an unknown phage in fact the bacterial
cell for the first time
the dna of the invader is being inserted
into the crispr array and from that
moment on
cell gains immunity against this type of
invader
next time this type of phage is
attacking the same cell or its offspring
the crispr machinery is activated and
serves as a
yeah as a kind of immune system
and
this system has laid the foundation for
how to use crispr as a molecular biology
tool in genome engineering
genome engineering helps understand the
role and function of a gene
so in a reverse genetic approach for
example a gene of interest would be
deleted and the effects of such a
mutation analyzed um questions that
would come up are how does the gene
affect morphology or the transcriptome
does the gene have an impact on the cell
cycle or the metabolism
do i see for example changes in the
proteome or in signaling pathways what's
actually happening on a genome level and
this interaction be it on a genetic or
in a cellular level impaired and the
mutation of the gene as you can see here
can have a bunch of effects on cells so
it is essential to use a reliable system
that just introduces the wanted
mutations without having additional side
effects and also without interfering
with other cellular mechanism
having a closer look into techniques for
genome editing in mammalian cells there
are three prominent techniques called
zinc fingernucleases talens and crispr
and all three methods are able to
specifically introduce mutations into
the genome
on the left and the middle there are
zinc fingernucleases and talons
they use for that a split nucleus that
is directed to the region of interest in
the genome
by proteins that specifically recognize
a sequence motive within the gene of
interest and both systems are well
suited for genome engineering however
the design of the left and the right
part of the constructs
which guides the split nucleus to the
region of interest
is is rather
is rather tricky i would say
um the crispr cast technology can also
be used for gene editing but um it works
a bit differently so here we have a
guide rna
that leads the endonuclease and in this
example on the right side it's cas9
and
this cas9 is guided to the gene of
interest and for that
a protospacer adjacent motif short pam
must be present in the genome but not in
the guide rna so once the pam is present
and the guide rna is perfectly matching
to the region of interest
the endonuclease is introducing a
double-stranded breaks and this
double-stranded breaks needs to be
urgently repaired by cellular repair
mechanisms such as
non-homologous end joining on the left
and homology directed repair on the
right
when repaired by non-homologous end
joining the double-stranded break is
randomly repaired by either removing or
adding some base pairs so the outcome in
such an experiment would be cells
carrying all different kinds of indels
and we see we will see that later and in
this presentation
when repairing via homology directed
repair
then a donor dna
is additionally needed and delivered
into the cells
that
serves as a template on how to fix the
break in the genome and
with that
the outcome so the outcome goes more in
a yes or no direction so either it's
edited or it's not edited and both
methods are widely used depending on the
individual experimental setup
so depending on what kind of
genome engineering is used the crispr
strategy is changing and unfortunately
there is no one crispr workflow that
would fit all scenarios
but what all of the approaches have in
common is that they all start with the
target gene and
the before starting with the editing
event itself it is important to choose
the corresponding editing strategy and
it really depends on the experimental
setup
sometimes a plasmid strategy might be
preferred over an rnp setup and of
course vice versa is also the case
depending on the target gene
the choice of the guide rna and with
that also of course the choice of the
endonuclease is crucial
and depending on the cell type and of
course the crispr method of choice
there are several possibilities on how
to get the crispr components into the
cells
such as lipofaction electroporation
nuclear faction and so on so some cell
types for example can only be
transformed by electroporation
whereas other cell types do not tolerate
electroporation at all
all those steps have a major impact on
the
analysis of editing events so the more i
optimize the three steps a longer work
along the crisper workflow the better
the outcome and the less effort is
needed for screening and finding the
cell carrying the mutation of interest
when i did my first crispr experiment
and this was back in 2017
i was working on a transcription factor
regulating the unfolded protein response
and i wanted to quickly generate a
knockout cell line
to be able to analyze the effects of
this transcription factor
i wanted to be done with that in just a
couple of weeks since from literature it
did not seem to be too difficult i
wanted to delete
my gene of interest in two different
cell lines
with five deletion approaches
including of course non-homologous end
joining and
homology directed repair and
yeah i used several crispr editing
techniques and two different delivery
strategies just i wanted to be on the
safe side just in case that one of the
strategies
is not as straightforward as expected
also for cell phone isolation i used
several methods and it took me i think
about the month before i could start
screening for the cell clone harboring
the added of interest
and
back then i was quite confident that it
is just a matter of days until i have my
knockout cell line in hand
however
as you might imagine the screening
process took an unexpected turn so
since all the available
antibodies against my transcription
factors were not working i had to screen
on a dla dna level
i had multiple dna extraction methods
combined with
with different
pcr chemistries
and
yeah clone number
670 was finally the knockout clone i was
looking for
and
all in all it took me around two months
of cell cultivation and screening and i
can tell you two very laborious and
frustrating months
and
it was just later on that i realized
that this
was not just me with the deletion of my
favorite transcription factor
but challenges along the gene editing
and screening process can occur and
sometimes no matter how much you
optimize or how much optimization is
involved
several hundreds of cell clones need to
be cultivated and screened to obtain the
cell with the added of interest
there are different factors that can
make screening for the gene added of
interest long and tedious and some of
them are listed here on this slide
so let's start with low editing
efficiency
low editing efficiency may result in us
in a greater screening effort however
sometimes boosting the editing
efficiency might also increase unwanted
off-target events and this can
negatively impact for example
self-fitness
can result in a reduced survival rate or
also in a reduced cell growth and
proliferation
and this in turn significantly increases
the cell cultivation effort
and one thing that we should always
always keep in mind is that
the longer we cultivate the cells the
older they are
and of course they have more time to
collect mutations and those mutations
can affect the whole downstream analysis
and last but not least
sometimes lots of cell clones as i told
you already need to be screened and the
target gene is in most cases amplified
by a pcr and for that you need specific
but at the same time also very efficient
primers
and this primer design sometimes
requires expertise to avoid
some major pcr optimization later on
and depending on the experimental setup
the gene of interest and the editing to
be introduced
you can face a variety of of challenges
most editing workflows
can be roughly split into three steps
once the crispr editing has taken place
the cell
the cells need to be processed and the
dna extracted and in most cases
the lower the editing efficiency the
higher the screening f word
next the target of interest is amplified
by a pcr so for that specific primers
and efficient primers as well as a
robust pcr chemistry are needed
and last but not least editing needs to
be somehow analyzed and
for example wireless angle sequencing
and here again
sanger sequencing primers are required
and the sequencing traces also needs to
be evaluated
in the following
i would like to guide you through the
three steps one by one highlighting some
bottlenecks and providing some tips and
tricks on how to simplify and to speed
up the process so let's start with
sample preparation
there are many different methods i know
that there are many different methods
available on how to extract dna from
different salts
and for crispr screening purposes the
easiest and fastest way to do that is
to directly lyse the cells and to use
the raw lysate for target amplification
without additional purification steps
so one of the major differences here
between the various sample preparation
techniques
is the amount of cells to start with
and and this is very crucial especially
when dealing with high mortality after
crispr editing or when working with
single cells as shown here
so after cloning expansion you start
with just one single cell and for
example a sampler preparation method
that's that requires a thousand cells
would involve 11 days of cultivation for
um for cells that have a generation time
of 24 hours
don't worry i added one day here since
we always need to keep the clone alive
if all cells are lysed
without the backup there is nothing left
after cell lice so one would need to
start with the editing all over again
and at that example it would of course
be beneficial to choose a sample
preparation method that only requires a
couple of cells reducing cell
cultivation time
and also resulting in younger and fed
results
we at
kyogen developed a liquid-based sample
preparation method that enables dna
preparation from just a few cells and as
you can see here on this slide
a broad range of cell
input is applicable and we can even go
below 10 cells per microliter of lysis
popper
so the sample preparation is um
compatible with different experimental
setups so we can go with six well plates
24 well plates 96 well plates every kind
of imaginable
experimental setup
and
the sample preparation takes less than
30 minutes even
and i was also surprised but
i experienced it myself even when
preparing 96 samples at one goal
next
now we have the lysate and next
the target of interest needs to be
amplified by a pcr using
the sample prepared in step one
but without additional purification
steps so this would be the optimal
scenario
and what do we need for that so first of
all we need a
pcr chemistry
that is sensitive enough to deal with
the raw cell lysate containing just a
few cells
and with that of course also containing
just a limited number of target copies
to be amplified
so as you can see here we combined the
raw cell lysate from step one
with kyogen's all-tech pcr chemistry and
um we prepared lysates with different
cell numbers per microliter of isos
buffer from different cultured cells
such as eurocut hela neutral s cells and
so on
and we always transferred 5 microliter
of lysate into the pcr reaction
in this example you can see the
amplification of em x1
from half a cell on the left side to
five to fifty thousand cells sorry um
per reaction on the right side and as
you can see
one cell is already sufficient for
successful amplification of emx one
and this of course may vary depending on
the target of interest however
also with other target genes fuse outs
are already sufficient for successful
target amplification
for the amplification of emx 1 we used
in this experiment crispr q custom
design pcr primers but this would also
perfectly work with
yeah let's say good self design primers
but i will come back to the primer
design topic
in a minute
next
the pcr chemistry should also be robust
against inhibitors that might affect pcr
performance so
when cultivating cells different types
of potential inhibitors such as
transfection transduction coding agents
and so on can be carried over into the
pcr
and we tested the inhibitory effects of
different components as shown in this
list and i i would say i have good news
for you so
our all-tech pcr chemistry is very
robust towards these reagents and this
allows us to use the dna from the raw
cell lysate without any further
purification prior to pcr
and also without the addition of
laborious cell washing steps and this is
very important not just because
it's always good to save time
but especially when working with fuel
cells um being able to skip the washing
step is is a great benefit since every
washing step also leads to loss of cell
material and in this
and this is something that you
definitely want to avoid as good as
possible
and last but not least
um a pcr chemistry that allows flexible
lysate input is very beneficial so
usually as i said we would transfer
five microliter of raw s8 in a 20
microliter pcr reaction
but what if i want to save on lysate
because i do not have too much or the
lysate is too thin and i need to use
more to avoid undercutting the lower
limit of detection
so in that case we would need a system
that allows to use either less or more
lysate in the pcr reaction and this is
exactly what we can do when using the
all-tech pcr chemistry in combination
with the lysate prepared with kyogen's
new liquid-based sample preparation
method
so as you can see here the lysate volume
can be increased from 5 microliter to 14
microliter in just a 20 microliter pcr
reaction and even if not shown
the same holds true with reducing the
lysate volume in a pcr reaction for
example from five microliter to just one
microliter and that
very important without affecting of
course the pcr performance
now
we have the lysate and the pcr chemistry
and as i already mentioned for a
successful target amplification
the corresponding target pcr primers are
needed it all starts with the genomic
dna sequence as you can see on the left
side of this slide
and of course the identification of the
editing sites then two primers left and
right with specific melting temperatures
are placed next to the editing site
and the primers should amplify a
reasonably long fragment which means the
fragment should be as short as possible
and as long as needed and this looks
very simple on the slide however
to design specific and efficient primers
some kind of design expertise is
required
and that was the reason why we decided
to develop on gene globe a
crispr-specific design tool for human
mouse and breadth targets
and for the design on gene globe
only the species the genomic location of
the gene added and the guide rna
sequence is used
that or the guide rna sequence that was
used for the crispr editing experiment
is needed and based on that
um in silico validated
crisp eq custom pcr primers
are fully customized designed
and those primers would generate then a
pcr product of 400 to 600 base pairs
the pcr products are later on compatible
with
sanger sequencing analysis but also with
mismatched cleavage essays such as at7
essay and this directly leads me to the
last step in our workflow which is the
editing analysis
once the target has been amplified via
pcr
um additional analysis are required to
see whether the editing of interest were
successful or not and therefore sanger
analysis for sanger sequencing is
suitable
for that
as i already said sangha the sanger
sequencing primers are needed and
the gene globe primer design tool that i
showed you for
ecr primary design
it's also designing cyanoprimer so that
for every pcr primer fair there's also
the corresponding as we call it best
match crisper qsenga primus and since we
always recommend to sequence a pcr
product from the five prime as well as
from the three prime end
both primers are designed and
would result in sequence traces with
more than 100 base pairs of high quality
data
um those sanger sequence traces can also
be analyzed on gene globe using the
crispr qsanger analysis tool and for
that only a sanger trace of control and
sample and again the guide rna sequence
that was used for editing is needed and
based on this information
the non-edited sequence trace is aligned
with the editing sequence trace and this
editing efficiency is then calculated on
an allele level in this experiment for
example we performed a non-homologous
and joining crispr editing
and analyze the editing efficiency in a
cell pool and on the left you can see
the indoor spectrum
and approximately 20 of the alleles
had either one base pair inserted or
deleted
of course always compared to the
non-edited white type control and on the
right side you can find some more
information on what exactly was inserted
in case of the one
base per insertion event in this
experiment
um fifty percent of the alleles had an
adenine insertion
twenty-five percent of the aliens had a
building insertion and in twelve point
five percent of the cases
either a c or a t
could be found at this position and with
those results in hand it is easier for
example to decide how many cell clones
need to be screened
if the editing experiment needs to be
repeated or if it's worth considering
maybe a totally different editing
strategy
in a nutshell
once the crispr editing experiment has
been performed the screening for results
containing the added of interest starts
we at kyogen work on a characterization
workflow that unifies sample preparation
target amplification including the
primer design
and editing analysis so our new kaya
prep and m crisper kit
contains everything needed for the
liquid-based sample preparation
from cultured cells derived from human
mouse or red salts
here the cells are washed analyzed by
the addition of the provided lysis
buffer after just 15 minutes of
incubation at room temperature the lysis
reaction is stopped by incubation at 80
degrees for 10 minutes
the raw lysate does not need any further
purification step as as i could show you
and can either be directly used in a pcr
or stored at -20 degrees
everything needed for the target
amplification is
also provided in the kaya prep and m
crisper kit and the cell lysate together
with some target specific primers are
then used in the pcr reactions
the primers can be either self-designed
or designed using the crispr as a design
tool on gene group
and the pcr chemistry and the lysate are
of course particularly suited together
with the crispr q custom pcr assays
besides the pcr primers also sanger
primers can be designed with the gene
globe tool and last but not least the
sanger sequence traces can be analyzed
using the sanger analysis tool which
also can be found on on jingle
all in all
we developed
an innovative fast and sensitive
characterization workflow that combines
a liquid-based sample preparation
with target amplification primary design
and also sanger analysis
and all that looks at the end like that
the small blue kitchen box contains
everything needed for sample preparation
target amplification and is called kaya
prepping crisper kit
and the custom pcr primers
crisper q
custom pcrs is for pcr and crisper
qsanger pc um sorry and the crisper q
sanger primers for sanger sequencing are
optional and not included in the
chiropractor crispr kit
with that
i'm at the end of the presentation and i
would like to thank all of you for
participating in today's webinar so if
you have questions please use the q a
function and i'm very happy to take them
so um okay i see one question here that
is
can guide rna longer than 20 base pairs
be used with cas9 the wild type from sp
and still efficiently generate
double-stranded breaks
um
so yeah
with every endonuclease that can be used
for um crispr editing there is also a
perfect matched um
guide rna so if there is a if if you're
using a cas9 that tolerates
guide rnas then more longer than 20 base
pairs then it should work
there are also class 12 enzymes that
work with a bit longer guide rnas so
it really depends on the
on the endonuclease that is
being used
um
then we have another question do you
need to purify your validation pcr
products
so
as i said prior to pcr there is no
purification needed however for example
if you're doing
if you're going with sanger sequencing
then of course there is um
a purification is definitely needed
because you would carry over the pcr
components into the sanger sequencing
and the sanger sequencing would uh
majorly be affected by the dntps by the
buffer
by the primers and everything so before
pcr no purification is needed after pcr
purification is needed and if you decide
to use the pcr fragment for t7 um for
for example for a t7 essay then
there's also no need to have a
purification since
the chemistry that we used is mostly
compatible with t7sa for example
um
then we have
that's the crisper kit work on
prokaryotes
um so our chiroprap and m crispr kit is
optimized
for usage with human mouse and
red cells
and um
so
but i mean at the end if the lysis
buffer of course can also work with
other types of um sample input and also
the pcr chemistry is not just limited to
higher eukaryotes or to human mouse and
red however
um
the the primer design on gene globe this
would not work um so the the primer
design tool that we have on gene group
is very limited to
human mouse and red cells but the rest
the lysis buffer and the pcr chemistry
um from the kaya prep and crispr kit
would could also work
with other than human moss and red cells
so then here we have
another question
when characterizing edits using sanger
sequencing no cloning of pcr products is
required yes
yes actually when i did
my crispr experiment during my phd i was
also cutting out the bands of a gel and
cloning it in a vector and then
sequencing it from a vector
um i learned that kyogen that this is
not needed if you have specific ptr
products and this is this is a must to
have a clean
um high yield pcr product and when you
have that there is no need um to to go
with additional cloning and peri and
extraction from gels or something like
that
so
the pcr product can directly be analyzed
in sanger sequencing if
you have
a specific pcr product if there is
additional pcr products and specific
products that you can see on a gel or
also when using the kayak cell then of
course one would need to optimize the
pcr
or um to go
um
yeah
to go with the purification maybe from
from an agarose gel just old-fashioned
way that always works
then we have here another question um
is the kia jin crisper series kit for
research use or clinical use um yeah so
the kit that we have is as
disclaimed from from paula is for
research use
um here we have another question i'm
working with long inserts knock-ins and
have challenges to amplify them is your
method limited to a specific insert
length
this is a question that we get quite
often um
as you might all know the longer the pcr
fragment the more difficult it is of
course to amplify it this this is just
how it is however
our all-tech
pcr chemistry in combination with the
lysis buffer that
we have is able also to amplify longer
fragments such as 5 kb
and the limitation is with 9 kb so our
all-tech um
master mix together with the lysis
buffer and the chia prep and crispr kit
is able to amplify even 9 kb long
pcr fragments however of course as you
might
as you can imagine
there is some
a bit more optimization required for
example
one pcr cycling of course cannot be used
for the amplification of
500 base pairs and 9000 base pairs at
the same time so this is of course not
the case but we have in our handbooks in
the old tech handbook and also in our
crispr handbook some guidance on how to
get also
long pcr fragments
amplified
without major troubles
then this we have this one let me see if
you have more question
is it compatible with other pcr reagents
such as x tech from takara
so in our kaya proper m crisper kit
there is the lysis buffer and the all
tech
pcr chemistry together
so with the lysis we
we we have an easy and reliable way on
how to extract dna
and this dna
is of course also
compatible with other chemistries
however
we optimize our chemistries to
perfectly work together
so
this is um
this is what we worked on so you will
get best results when combining the
lysis buffer together with the all-tech
chemistry which is very robust and is
even able to um
yeah to amplify long fragments
and this combination works best
um
okay i see
another
i see
here we have another one um
can i use the kaya prep and um crisper
and the crisper q primers for the
characterization of gene edits that were
introduced with talons
yes
so the crispr the the chiropractor kit
is called has crisper in its name but
however um as you seen in my very first
um interest in in my second introduction
slide um
starting from the editing the
characterization is the same the only
thing that you need to keep in mind here
is
for example
when using our primary design tool we
need this the guide rna sequence and in
that case you would just take the
sequence around
the cut side that
was introduced with talons or also zinc
finger nucleus so
um the kyle prep and i'm crispy kit
works also for talents editing and also
for zinfandel new cases however
when using our primary design tool
then
just use
a region around the cutting side and use
this
as a guide rna so take 20 to 25 base
pairs and just go for it it it will work
so how many types of samples have you
tried using the lysis buffer what are
they
so we optimized our proper crispr kit
for cultured
for cultured
human mouse and red cells adherent see
me adherent
i forgot that he seemed here and and
suspension cells sorry
and
um
yeah we we worked with clumping cells
with slow dividers with very fast
dividers and
yeah the the the kit is compatible with
all kind of cultured cells derived
from
human mouse red
then we have another question here
um
is kyogen's crisper characterization
workflow also applicable to tricky
targets
i am working on gc rich target that form
stable secondary structures
yes so um
one component that we also added to the
child prep and m crisper kit is a q
solution and this q solution as um
sometimes helping with tricky targets
that have high gc content or form stable
secondary structures so this is one
option how to deal and how to be able to
um
to amplify tricky targets
and there is also alternative pcr
cyclings that
you could use for example increasing the
denaturation time
of um
of
of your pcr cycling and we also have
guidance um for that in in our handbook
so check it out um there's definitely
some options that we offer to deal with
tricky targets
exactly so
happy uh sorry i had this question i
just forgot um to click on that
now here we have a good one here so can
the crispr kits be used for cells edited
with several guide rnas or a guide rna
pool um
yes and no
so the kaya prep and m crispr kit
works with every kind of
crisper editing
so it doesn't matter if i worked with
two guide rnas
the the lysis and the pcr is not
affected afterwards however
when choosing to use the primer design
tool on gene globe then
we have some specifications for that
since the design algorithm works in a
way that
the gene editing site is identified and
the primers are
designed left and right of this
editing site so if i use two guide rnas
i would lose a piece of dna and there of
course chances are are there that the
primers are located in the piece of dna
that i lost
so when using multiple guide rnas then
kaya prep and m crisper kit is fine and
the the primer the sink the sanger
sequencing primers and the pcr primers
here um
i would say to take care and see if it
works or in case of doubt just to
contact us
and
ask if this would work or not
ah yeah here is there anything to
consider when processing
cultured cells on coated cultivation
dishes are additional purification step
required to eliminate or reduce coating
reagents such as polylyzine
that's a very good question and i was
also um
at the beginning i was
a bit concerned to just for example have
a six a coated six well cells on it and
just to scrape it off and have this high
concentrated coating agent in my pcr
reaction but it perfectly works and you
saw the whole list of reagents that we
tested so if you have
coated cultivation dishes
you will carry over the coating agent
into the pcr but the old tech pcr
chemistry is robust enough to deal with
that so here no additional purification
steps um are needed which which i really
like because if you have cells that are
not not nicely sticky then just um and
and you want to use a coating agent it's
it's it's not a problem for the
kyaprapanam crisper kit afterwards
okay
we had this one
my computer is a bit slow sorry for that
um we have here one question not sure if
i got it correctly but um let's give it
a try so how do you solve problems with
multiple alleles which are not always
all added at dirty sanger
so we have the sanger analysis tool on
gene globe and this analysis tool is
able to um also analyze sanger
sequencing coming from a pool
so in this pool as you can imagine you
will not have just a clean
trace but there will be several traces
depending on
on the editing that has
taken place in the cell and here the
algorithm
is um identifying the cut side so decide
from where on the sequence starts to get
ugly let's call it ugly and it aligns
the part before of the um
upstream of the editing and then it
starts calculating on all kind of
different events that might that that
happened after the cut
so the sender analysis tool is able to
use this decomposition
um strategy to um
separate different sanger traces and to
get a
editing efficiency result for that i
hope
this this answers your question
do you have any recommendations for
working with single cell clones when
using cells that have trouble
proliferating when not in clumps such as
in ipscs
been there what clumping cells is
it's not very easy but at the end this
is how the cells um are behaving
and
there is no
no right question no right answer for
this question since
it really depends on the cell type so
for the lysis it doesn't matter if it's
in clumps or not because when you put
the lysis buffer on the cells you just
um also pipe it up and down and this
mechanical pipetting would um
efficiently lies the cells within the
clump
um
so the problem is more on the
cultivation side but
i think this is this is a topic for
a completely other
webinar because it's so diverse and
there's so many things that one could
do it really depends on the cell line
but for the lies is no worry if you have
clumps
doesn't matter for um for the downstream
analysis along the workflow and also
when you um
need to estimate the cell number you
don't need to be like precise to
one single cell in in the clump um it's
also just um sufficient to start adding
the lysis buffer and then at the
beginning it will be viscous and then
you just add more lysis pepper and when
you see this
that the viscosity is going down then
you're perfectly fine and this is the
license that you want to work with
and do with the pcr on
so
okay
uh would you ever select such
heterozygous clones
for downstream work
i'm yeah this is this is maybe
a more um
personal questions let's say it like
that
i'm coming from fungal genetics and
as a as a fungal geneticist
um we want to have it ever very clean
and only homozygous um edits are
considered real edits um however i know
that in higher eukaryotes this is very
very difficult and it really depends on
what you want to do of course if
for example during my phd i wanted to
see
what kind of effects i get when deleting
my transcription factor of course having
it in a heterozygous state
might have kind of a knock down and i
have reduced levels of the transcription
factor and i'm pretty sure that also
then you would see some differences in
with transcriptome or um
in the phenotype however
when you really need a knockout then i
think um yeah the heterozygous clones
they still produce um the gene of
interest and the protein of interest
so it really depends for example if you
have a knock-in and you do a gfp tag
then of course you can screen um and you
do morphological analysis at the
microscope then just screen for the
greens and that's fine however if you
have a mixture of homozygous and
heterozygous clones then um there's also
always a danger that
the heterozygous clones have um an
advantage in growing and that's after a
couple of passages then you will get
yeah you will lose your homozygous um
clones and you will end up just with
heterozygous clones so it really depends
there is no
right or wrong answer to this question i
would say
i'm working with cell pools and i'm
wondering what i need to consider when i
screen my editing with your kit
great um
so
i focus in the presentation a bit more
on what to do if i just have little
material or just less cells but um our
kaya prep crisper solution is of course
also applicable
to um crispr experiments where lots of
salts are present such as when working
with cell pools
there is nothing much to consider it's
just a lysis step so if you have a
million of salts
then it's it's
a couple of more microliter of lysis
buffer are needed and we would suggest
to go with 10
to 3 000 cells per microliter of lysis
buffer of course you could have also
more cells per microliter of lysis
buffer but at some point the lysate as i
already said gets very viscous and
bubbly and then
so it's more difficult to transfer
the lysate into the pcr reaction and so
on but um we also have a protocol in our
handbook on how to just simply dilute
the amount of cells and to have a
reasonable cell number per microliter of
lysis buffer and this is absolutely no
problem so there is not much um
that needs to be considered and if you
feel like that it's still too viscous
just add more lysis buffered as simple
as that
okay
i think
do you see any more questions paula
no and i think we are also running out
of time
i would like to quickly mention to our
audience that we will send you in the
next day's email with webinar recording
um
and with that i want to thank you all
for attending our webinar and i also
want want to thank you domenica for
joining us today
i will close now the session
and i wish you all a great rest of the
day thank you again
see you bye bye bye
you